Los Angeles Dodgers won the first game
of the World Series last night exciting
time to be in LA yeah interesting fact
last night's game was the fastest World
Series game in decades yeah yeah fans in
LA we're at the game for two and a half
hours and in traffic for five and a half
so it worked out yeah this is weird a
Joe Biden made an announcement today to
hear his announcement when asked about
the 2020 election Joe Biden said I
haven't decided to run but I've decided
I'm not going to decide not to run yeah
yeah then his wife Jill Biden said
welcome to my hell my private private
hell in a late-night vote yesterday the
Senate made it illegal to sue a bank
yeah they made it illegal to sue a bank
yeah which is why today Harvey Weinstein
petition to become a bank
in the past week several prominent men
have been fired for sexual harassment
it's being called the Harvey effect it's
being called the Harvey effect yeah of
course none of them will see any jail
time that's being called The Cosby
effect I love a crowd that ooze as they
applied I'm onto you guys I'm on to you
experts say the new blockbuster movie
geo storm may lose as much as 100
million dollars yeah yeah after hearing
about it Nicolas Cage said hey I don't
remember starring in that
and then I got to mention this has been
reported that Britain's Queen Elizabeth
Queen Elizabeth has earned over eight
million dollars from horse-racing yes
yes
today the Queen said two grand more and
I quit this [ __ ] job
I should make it clear she doesn't ride
the horses she's betting I was realizing
as I said it it sounds a little bit like
91 year old play another welcome
you